planning a role in a Marvel movie means
potential start of up-and-coming actors
renewed popularity for aging vets and a
fat paycheck for anyone willing to dawn
a cool metal fruit but despite bobbles
impact on the modern movie business
not every actors came to put on a mask
and do battle with alien armies here are
a few actors who refused big Marvel
roles Russell Crowe these days Marvel
movies are guaranteed to bring in big
numbers at the box office but before the
year 2000 that wasn't necessarily the
case fortunately things started to
change for Marvel when Bryan Singer's
x-men first hit the big screen it's
credited as the film that gave rise
there's a modern era of superhero movies
and transforms Hugh Jackman from a stage
performer into a Hollywood a-lister but
according to actor it was pure luck he
got the part in the first place at one
point the filmmakers turn to Russell
Crowe to play Wolverine who was fresh
off the set of gladiator
however Crowe turns the part down for a
reason that well a little weird
well I've just done a character whose
animal totem was all that feller Max and
gladiator come on be connected to the
wolf of course Crowe further clarified
his reasoning and plus it's a cartoon
what are you I'm not really into those
yeah but that didn't really stop him
from appearing in Man of Steel luckily
for superhero fans everywhere she did
recommend that Bryan Singer go which you
Jackman who'd previously auditioned for
the part Matt Damon as long as we try no
one can forget 2003 daredevil while the
Ben Affleck flicks did well financially
critic or depart when asked about the
film and 2016 Affleck responded they
hated daredevil so much you know I mean
not to me now you
I said okay don't go bathroom it turns
out that athlete could have been spared
all that embarrassment if his best
friend should accept as the world first
Matt Damon was offered the part of
daredevil and it was a pretty tempting
deal since Damon and Affleck considered
Dedham to be their favorite superhero
but when Damon was approached with the
project reportedly he just wasn't
impressed with the script or familiar
enough with the director Affleck saying
are and who's come to regret that
decision but at least Daredevils failure
inspired him to get his next superhero
movie right Joseph gordon-levitt over
the years there have been a lot of
whispers about Joseph gordon-levitt in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe but JGL
has denied them all from Doctor Strange
to enman nevertheless according to
Deadline the actor was in the running
for the role Peter quill aka Starwood
which he allegedly turned down to play
the character of Johnny in sin city a
dame to kill for which probably wasn't a
great choice for gordon-levitt but we're
pretty happy with Chris Pratt Olivia
Munn went Deadpool hit status in early
2016
Ruba goers went while so the film's
raunchy humor and bloody shootout x-men
apocalypse on the other hand wasn't
quite so successful limping away from
theaters with a rotten tomato score of
48 percent but none of these numbers
really mattered to Olivia Munn before
starting up to play the role of
psylocke in x-men one was first offered
the role of Vanessa Carlysle Deadpool
scrappy girlfriend Munn turned the pod
down in favor of playing the spandex
clad butan saying that she wasn't
interested in playing the protagonist by
candy instead she wanted to be a
character with powerful abilities
extreme fighting skills and a costume
there's pretty much Underpants
Mel Gibson it was a cruise for Marvel's
movies when Award winner Anthony Hopkins
agreed to join the MTU as Odin
all-father and king of Asgard well he
seemed like it obvious picked for the
role he wasn't the only actor in the
running for
the old father in an interview with The
Guardian Mel Gibson explained that he
was asked to play Odin but as he simply
put it I didn't do it
at first glance the action star seems
like an odd pick to play the stately
North God but with a solid background in
Shakespearean theatre Gibson probably
would have felt comfortable with Odin's
aristocratic dialog of course with all
the controversy surrounding the actor it
was probably best to be empty knew that
Gibson turned down the part Jessica
Chastain Iron Man 3 was the second
highest grossing domestic movie of 2013
and it's praise and profit isn't
undeserved audiences enjoyed witty
dialogue a brilliant plot twist and one
of the greatest ending set pieces of
Marvel movie history the only thing it
really lacked was Jessica Chastain the
studio wanted Chastain to play the part
of Maya Hansen a scientist who may or
may not be on Tony Stark side
unfortunately Chastain had to pass on
the role because she was just too busy
she said to a Facebook fan I know many
of you want me to be involved and I'm
sorry to disappoint hopefully there will
be another Marvel film in my future of
course it isn't like Chastain decision
hurt her career after she turned down
the role it went to Rebecca Hall
originally Maya Hansen was supposed to
be the ultimate villain of the film but
someone up the chain of command ordered
writers director Shane Black to make the
bad guy a dude because female action
figures supposedly don't sell that well
leaving Hall in a much less important
role than anticipated
Joaquin Phoenix when Marvel Studios was
preparing to introduce audiences to dr.
Stephen strange there were a few names
at the top of their list they were
allegedly interested in the likes of
Jared Leto and Ryan Gosling but it seems
like in Phoenix came even closer to
landing the gig the oscar-nominated star
ultimately decided to partially sorcerer
supreme because he didn't feel as he
would do well in his studio full of
green screen and the role went to
Benedict Cumberbatch however there was a
brief bit of time where it seems
Cumberbatch wouldn't be able to wear the
cloak of levitation as he
already signed up to play Hamlet in a
London stage production to accommodate
Cumberbatch's schedules the sugar ended
up pushing back dr. Strange's release
day Emily Blunt Marvel realized Emily
Blunt action star potential long before
the rest of it as Kevin Feige and Jon
Favreau had to shoot behind mentors they
also be English actors one of the
biggest roles in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe Natasha Romanov aka
Black Widow unfortunately for blunt a
timing just didn't work out she was busy
with the Jack black comedy Gulliver's
Travels and had to part from playing the
Russian super spy which was a pretty
huge mistake Marvel still really wanted
Blunt to join the MCU
so when it came time to film Captain
America the First Avenger execs asked if
she'd be interested in playing Steve
Rogers capable of interest Megan Carter
once again the timing was off and the
pod went to Hayley Atwell in a 2012
interview with vulture one admitted that
she's still open to a superhero role as
long as she gets to play a hero saying
usually the female parts in a superhero
film feel thankless she's the Pihl
girlfriend while the guys are whizzing
around saving the world Matthew
McConaughey have you seen guardians of
the galaxy it's easy to see why people
are incredibly psyched for inside my
sequel and it seems like any actor in
Hollywood would gladly sign up for a
trip to Xandar for example both
Sylvester Stallone and Kurt Russell will
appeal alongside Chris Pratt but despite
all the excitement not every actor is
willing to soar off into space with
star-lord in an interview with slavery
Oscar winner Matthew McConaughey said he
was offered a role in volume 2 but
turned it down to appear in an
adaptation of Stephen King's The Dark
Tower saying I like got into the galaxy
but what I saw was it's successful and
now we've got room to make a colorful
part for another big-name actor I'd feel
like an ammendment McConaughey didn't
say which part he was offered in volume
2 though most agree he would have played
a villain still the Guardian sequel
should be plenty of fun even without
McConaughey in the film though it would
be a lot
kula if you signed up action and there's
the chick alright alright thanks for
watching click the blue icon and
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll want to
[Music]